you
um
i think we have aaron joining us here
me
erin how are you hey doing well how are
you i'm doing fantastic doing fantastic
just just trying to
go through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends here as you know we do
here on the show um i know i wanted to
bring you on to give us uh
a little update of ukraine to let
everyone know you're an attorney you're
a democratic strategist um you also are
the co-host of zoomed in podcast but
more importantly you have been keeping
track of this ukraine news not only
because it is of interest to you but you
do have family in ukraine is that
correct yeah that's correct i have an
uncle an aunt and a little nine-year-old
cousin so
wow so
um
are they are where where are in this in
the vicinity of ukraine because that
that's what interests me because it
seems like russia is is having success
in some regions but they're not in
others can you kind of explain why
that's important and what that means
about
um the rest of the world like is russia
going to take ukraine are they not can
you kind of give us an idea of how that
works yeah sure so i think what we've
seen is a really and honestly a complete
collapse of the russian military
strategy before this invasion occurred
back two weeks ago now vladimir putin
thought he could take ukraine within
three hours uh
united states officials and intelligence
believed that
russia could take ukraine within 72
hours we're now over two weeks in and as
you said russia's really only been able
to take certain outskirts um of ukraine
and only two large larger towns the town
of harassan which is in the south as
well as the town of mariupo which they
haven't officially took yet but they are
laying siege to the town and just today
over it was reported that over 1500
civilians have died in the past two
weeks as a result of the russian siege
now the reason why
russia hasn't been successful there are
really two reasons first ukrainian
resistance has been extremely strong and
honestly stronger than the russian
military and the russian government
expected uh many thought that president
zielinski because of his background not
many people know but president zielinski
literally was on the ukrainian version
of dancing with the stars just a few
years ago he was an actor he was a
comedian he wasn't this leader type so
many thought that he would easily just
roll over and leave the country or just
surrender and he hasn't done that and
ukrainian forces have really rallied
around president zielinski so they have
fought back significantly that's number
one number two is russian morale is
really at an all-time low now yesterday
i was at the
pleasure of joining a white house
briefing where uh the senior national
security uh
member from the national security
council said that russian morale is low
because russians are don't know what
they're fighting for many of these
troops are being sent into war right now
in ukraine to
not just fight um
well they're being sent for reasons that
they don't know um they haven't been
told by their military leadership why
they're invading ukraine they cannot
personally justify the invasion because
in a lot of ways they're fighting their
brothers and sisters right many
ukrainians speak russian many ukrainians
grew up under the former ussr when it
was one country and many russian
soldiers don't understand why they're
fighting this war and so you've seen a
lot of defections you've seen a lot of
russian soldiers surrender to ukraines
to ukrainian forces and you've seen the
russian military just not be able to
gain ground
now with that being said
um
i personally believe based on what i've
been covering what i've seen that if
russia continues its invasion if russia
continues putting forth the forces that
it has and is able to encircle kiev
which is its next plan key of the
capital of ukraine that it will be able
to take ukraine it will be able to
reinstall a russian government in
ukraine
now the ultimate goal of vladimir putin
isn't
necessarily to take land in ukraine
because a russia is already big enough
and b the land in ukraine isn't super um
it isn't strategically beneficial to
russia necessarily but rather vladimir
putin wants to recreate the former
soviet union through these proxy
governments he has one in belarus with
dictator lukashenko already um he had
one in ukraine when president yanukovych
victor yanukovych back in 2010 was
president but yanukovych has since fled
from ukraine and is being is been in
exile in russia and he wants to
reinstall yanukovych reinstall a
pro-russian government a demilitarized
ukraine quote unquote and um he he will
in my opinion will be successful in
doing that but it will just take a lot
longer um and at the end of the day like
president biden has said um i don't
think russia can call this a win even if
it is able to take ukraine the reason
why is because ukrainian morale is at an
all-time high russian morale is at an
all-time low and no matter what putin
does he's not going to be able to unify
the ukrainian people and that's going to
cause him a lot of headaches moving
forward um so although russia has the
military might that um
it theoretically could take over ukraine
if it continued pushing because ukraine
only has so many resources available to
to fight back um
he's already lost his war um in a lot of
ways
so
so that those are some good points that
you make and a lot of people have been
saying you know oh well if trump was
still president um
vladimir putin wouldn't go in ukraine
and isn't there a case to be made that
the reason why possibly putin wasn't
going to ukraine if trump was still
present is because he wouldn't have to
because he would have a president united
states who was trying to overthrow the
government essentially and undermine the
government of ukraine like yes why why
wh why why in the hell would vladimir
putin go into a country where the
president of the united states if it
were donald trump was helping him
undermine ukraine like he was the four
years he was
because we see the vice president which
i want to play that clip here she she
says
america stands ironclad behind article
five but we know the former president
probably didn't even know what article
five really was essentially
no you're 100 right and you hit it right
on the nail and i've said this many
times and is that yeah i do agree with
donald trump if donald trump was
president this invasion would not have
have occurred but for the reasons you
said not because donald trump was tough
on russia for whatever reason but rather
because donald trump during his four
years in office spent those four years
destabilizing ukraine he first um called
out nato and threatened to leave nato
every chance he got by thereby weakening
the nato alliance he then um remember he
was impeached for literally conditioning
um security guarantees and aid to
ukraine on the investigation of
political rivals um and and he spent and
he even spent time supporting the
russian government and supporting the
russian intelligence by in helsinki that
famous moment when he essentially agreed
with vladimir putin agreed with russian
intelligence and completely discounted
american intelligence that russia
meddled in the election
so yeah why would vladimir putin want to
disrupt that when trump is disrupting it
for him
so i think this invasion was planned for
a very long time not many people
realized but
this invasion has been occurring since
2014 when putin first went into crimea
um and i think putin expected to launch
a further invasion um but he didn't need
to over the past four years trump was
doing it for him trump set the set kind
of the
um
the groundwork for this invasion in a
lot of ways well you know you say it
goes back to crimea but i almost you
know you look back at uh vladimir putin
you know i don't know i think the guy's
mired in delusion now but you go all the
way back to the when they uh invaded
georgia
and even then even then you could almost
make the argument that that even then
this was part of the plan
now for sure whether vladimir putin
understood or had in his little uh in
his little ideas that trump would become
president he definitely wanted to use
the candidacy of trump to cause chaos
and then once trump became president i
think that kind of changed his game
plans and as he as he's watched trump
lose and not only lose he couldn't win
the big lie argument he couldn't win
overturning the election the january six
insurrection that you know they kept of
course trump loses all the time it's
just a loss after loss after loss
this guy's a loser um but as vladimir
putin watched that happen it became more
evident that he was going to have to do
what he wanted to do before trump became
president which was to do an occupation
of a sovereign nation which is ukraine
and and try to try to like you said
install his russian puppets into that
government um because
i think i think and i've been saying it
here is that
really vladimir putin's enemy
is democracy right um and ukraine and
you can speak to this better than i
think most because you do have family
there you do have ties there you do know
about the government there uh a little
better than most
ukraine is not a perfect democracy
um it's a very corrupt democracy but
in a world where if you rewind the clock
back to
before barack obama when george w bush
was president the republican party in
this country
would say things like oh we're trying to
spread democracy around the world
and we we fast forward all the way to
this moment and we have people in the
republican party who are not only
abandoning that idea but almost rooting
against democracy for putin because they
know that authoritarian figures whether
it be putin kim jong-un or their orange
deity donald trump
it it really does democracy is their
enemy it is not their friend and i think
that is ultimately part of
not putin just putin's delusion but his
ultimate task here is to undermine
democracy what's your thoughts no i i
agree 100 and i think that that's what
we've seen um during the trump
presidency and and the reason why
vladimir putin was so in favor of donald
trump's presidency
the russian government didn't care
whether it was donald trump or some
other madman in office in america what
their ultimate goal is is to sow
division in america
and you see you see that all the time
whether trump was president obama was
president bush was president biden's
president doesn't matter and now even to
this day the russian government is
parroting the um idea that uh that
because uh that we're here today because
of the big lie essentially what donald
trump um himself has said and and the
only reason they're doing that is
because they're trying to sow division
in america and they're trying to disrupt
democracies around the globe and and i
think you make an interesting point and
a critical point in that um
our the republican mindset the brain
think of let's spread democracy has
substantially changed and you're right
that ukraine is not a perfect democracy
but also the definition of democracy if
you ask 10 people you're going to get 10
different answers because
no one really knows what democracy is um
but i do think ukraine is a democracy
it's not a perfect democracy it has a
a lot of corruption a lot of um issues
with oligarchs there and stuff like that
but ukraine didn't cause this war
ukraine's corruption did not cause this
war what caused this war was russia and
was vladimir putin's intent to invade a
sovereign nation to recreate the former
soviet union and my message to all these
republicans that are pro-russia or are
not necessarily pro-ukraine but
remaining neutral is at what point do
you step up at what point do you say
something because if he's able to take
ukraine in my opinion he will take
moldova next moldova is not a nato
country moldova is a small country close
to ukraine um and after that there's
nothing stops him from going into nato
countries yeah article 5 is a threat and
article 5 in theory um would mean that
the united states is brought into the
war but remember the united states is
thousands of miles away from europe we
are
separated by from russia by a major
tundra in siberia on one side and a
major ocean on the other side we will be
fine um but are you okay with vladimir
putin going into poland
latvia estonia um romania i mean where
does it stop when do you stand up and if
you don't stand up now um unfortunately
you're enabling vladimir putin to go
into these other countries and to
ultimately achieve his goal of gaining
this
power and making russia this preeminent
superpower that it once purported to be
you know i think i think all those are
are excellent points and and i it's it's
the article 5 issue of course
today we see these same republicans that
we're talking about here they're they're
saying
that that vice president kamala harris
is the worst vice president in history
in history because she went and defended
article 5. i have that clip here let me
let me see if i can play that clip and
then we'll we'll talk about it here
i've said many times
including this afternoon with the
president
and the president's leadership
but around the world and i will say it
here
america's
commitment
to article 5 is ironclad
we take very seriously
our role
and the relationships that we have
within the nato alliance
we take seriously
and are prepared to act
on the words we speak when we say
an attack against one
is an attack against all
i believe that that's uh very
significant and and a lot of people
don't know what article 5 is but the
reason
and this shouldn't be significant right
like the vice president united states
going over and defending article 5
shouldn't actually be significant it
should be just like that should be what
happens right the reason why it's
significant is because the last
administration not only not only scoffed
off article 5 but the president united
states was like [ __ ] nato it's worthless
and he even said he even said the words
what does it have to do with us right
and i think that's to your point that
you just made and the point that the
vice president is making here um so how
important do you think it is not only to
like you're saying to uh nato security
those nations in the eu but our security
to make sure
that article 5 stands it's absolutely
critical uh because when you think about
it yeah ukraine in in just ukraine or
just moldova in a vacuum may not impact
the united states the united states
substantially from a security
perspective but if vladimir putin moves
further west moves into more european
countries we see a lot of secondary
effects um just by just already i mean
our gas prices are skyrocketing not
because of president biden but because
of vladimir putin's invasion
and that those are only going to go up
inflation is only going to go up the
supply chain is only going to get more
disrupted if he continues this it's
going to turn into a global catastrophe
both economically but also humanitarian
wise where are all these refugees going
to go they're going to go to the united
states a lot of them and are are we
prepared to accept all these refugees i
would hope so but not many republicans
are um and
are on that same
wavelength i mean and and my thing is
it's like
i it's it's absolutely critical that as
a country that we uphold our agreements
with our allies um and one of those
agreements is this art this concept of
article five because
we would hope that if russia were to
launch a direct attack on us that our
allies in europe would also stand up and
say okay an attack on the united states
is an attack on us that includes germany
which has substantial ties to russia the
united kingdom um france and others um
and it do i think that article 5 here
will be eventually imposed
no um i don't think putin is
i'll caveat this with um i hope he isn't
crazy enough to go and attack nato
country but nothing i mean
i don't see anything stopping him right
now um other than his himself and his
own military and his own and all his own
defects um in the russian morale um so i
mean we'll see what happens i don't
think article 5 will be imposed i hope
it isn't imposed but if is it but if it
is imposed we need american troops on
the ground we need american troops
defending american sovereignty and amer
and our allies because if we don't
defend them eventually it's just going
to be a massive russia a massive china
and us and what are you going to do when
you have no allies right well you know
those those um you know i i like i like
the vision of you know what do you want
do you want just three world powers and
that's it or do you want to make sure
that there's you know competition as it
were if you're
considering a market uh speaking of
markets and gas prices um you know that
that is that is a lot of the
conversation around um this country
right now and they are blaming on the
administration but not only that the the
republicans back to the the putin
republicans um i i believe yesterday
mitt romney came out
and lindsey graham also and they were
trying to excoriate the pro-putin part
of their party which is basically the
entire party not only not only the
politicians but also the talking heads
like tucker carlson fox news oan and
newsmax um basically parroting and also
content creating for russian propaganda
literally content creating for russian
propaganda yeah mike pompeo and the like
but mitt romney i i found it very
laughable that yesterday uh he found one
inroad to uh to bipartisanship with the
migs um i believe that is something that
needs to happen but for mitt romney to
stand up all of a sudden and get in
front of a microphone and be like oh
yeah that's that's the thing we want to
do right i'll i'll stand up for that it
really it really uh i don't know i think
it's kind of like a wet fart and a white
thong it just it's not it's not really
can we take mitt romney seriously can we
take this stuff that they say seriously
like when we're talking about when we're
talking about uh russia and if if their
party is pro-putin can we really take
this stuff seriously i mean we we can
take it seriously from people like mitt
romney from people like liz cheney adam
kinsenger but when you think about it
they are the minority in the republican
party these days the majority of the
republican these days are the pro putin
the um america first uh republicans so
yes we can take what they say seriously
but
you need more than one senator in the
senate you need more than two members in
in the house so um you could only take
it so seriously to an extent so i so i
want to push back a little bit on the
mitt romney adam kindergarten and liz
cheney and i want to challenge you a bit
and the reason why is because i believe
that the what happened yesterday with
lindsey graham and mitt romney is they
see they see a little bit of a hallway
to get their party back does that make
sense so they've kind of lost their
party to the like you said the america
first let's go brandon nazis and really
because because they have this hallway
this little glimmer of light at the end
of this tunnel like oh maybe we can
maybe we can destroy trumpism
and get our party back to be anti-putin
right if we're anti-because that's a
really popular idea and it's going to
become more and more popular as he
becomes
as he commits more war crimes um do you
i i think i think my personal opinion is
is that's them trying to capture back
the old gop and get away from the gqp
and the q anon america first type thing
i don't think it's as genuine as people
want to believe and maybe i'm wrong i
mean listen it definitely could be um
and if this is what they want to use to
get back to the old guard of the gop i'm
all for it in my opinion um because at
the end of the day i want to defeat
trumpism and i'd rather have you have
two rational parties that can work
together that can negotiate with one
another and that can achieve real
solutions i would love to get to that
place we're not at that place we're not
anywhere close to that place but if this
is one step closer to that place i'll
take them for their word here and then
attack them on other issues because at
the end of the day something that i've
um
really preached when it comes to this
war and on my tick tock and elsewhere is
that war cannot be partisan we this is
one thing that has to unite us as
republicans as democrats and as
independents and unfortunately several
republicans have chosen a completely
different route but if there are
republicans out there that want to come
together with the administration and
with democrats and stand strong against
putin and russian aggression i'm all for
it because we need a strong face because
at the end of the day what does vladimir
putin want he wants a divided america so
if we can show a united america at least
in this context we're already hitting
him where it hurts the most
so
uh more good points by you and i
appreciate
going head-to-head here on that issue
but i i will say it's not just
republicans because what we've seen um
is tulsi gabbert is in the news this
morning well she's a republican well
right but you know
dino i guess you call it debt democrat
in nineteen
you know they always want to throw her
in
maybe we we we do the the dino um but uh
we also had two two democrats uh vote
against something the other day um which
was kind of disappointing
so it's not just republicans it also as
democrats not that not that democrats
shouldn't have the right to vote against
or be russian assets i guess i don't
know uh uh we'll find out and one thing
i do want to ask you before we leave
because i i believe that these war
crimes and i know you've been following
it very closely um that's one thing i
want to ask before you leave if i can if
you've got a few minutes for sure is
that
we saw the other day that uh the russian
army uh
bombed
a maternity hospital
and they've been committing uh what
seems like other war crimes do you
believe that uh this the these these
events are turning points uh in this
conflict to where um more of the world
uh because we did see china uh give some
push back to russia and we've seen some
other pushback now of course deutsche
bank did not
because they're you know uh they have
that uh money line i mean excuse me that
money relationship with russia but d do
you see that as putin's delusion
makes him and his army commit more and
more war crimes
what what do you think the effect is on
that i mean i think that russia is
already a pariah on the world stage i
don't think there's anything putin can
do to make it more so than it already
has been i mean unless he uses like
chemical or nuclear weapons obviously
i think that do you think maybe that's
his that's his goal here is because he's
just trying to push the limit and he
knows these are war crimes do you think
that might be part of it well i mean i
think that i i definitely could see him
using chemical weapons i don't see him
going nuclear but as far as him thinking
their war crimes when you think about
that concept of war crimes you don't
have an international police that are
going to go in and arrest vladimir putin
he doesn't have any actual
accountability his country is already
facing the tightest sanctions it can
countries like china saudi arabia india
and others are going to remain either
neutral or on russia's side and remain
economically involved because it
benefits them because china is not going
to ever be 100 in ukraine's corner right
um because it won't that doesn't benefit
them and when you think about it you
have um
all these complaints in the
international court of justice and the
international criminal court but
nothing's ever going to come from that
why because first the international
criminal court russia's not even a party
to the rome treaty that the rome statue
that created it so russia's not even
under its jurisdiction so throw that
aside and then the international court
of justice
all it's going to do is issue a
statement or a report outlining russia's
war crimes and then that's it and and
then maybe a captured general in ukraine
may be held that may be tried in the
hague but the chances that ever happens
are less than one percent so there
really is no accountability here for
vladimir putin he does want to push the
limits and he does have support in it i
mean he does have belarus's support he
does have other conflict for example i'm
not saying mexico supports this mexico
of course doesn't support this but
mexico has remained neutral india has
remained neutral china in a lot of ways
has remained neutral saudi arabia has
continued that oil um relationship with
russia so um until every country around
the world including countries like north
korea venezuela and belarus stand up to
russia russia's always going to have
kind of skin in the game with other
countries and um
i i don't know what i don't know if this
is a turning point i don't think this is
the turning point i actually think the
true war hasn't really even begun yet
right i think we're going to see an
increased amount of escalation in the
next several days as they try to take
kiev um but i think i think the turning
point will be either they a then taking
kiev or b
um them using chemical weapons and
hopefully neither happen but it's
looking likely that either either one
will occur
that that's that's uh that's
disappointing to hear but i i i think
that you being up on the facts and we do
appreciate you coming on you're welcome
back anytime tell us where where tell us
where everyone can find you because i
know you do a lot of tick tocks to keep
people up on this and you're constantly
tweeting uh news out so tell us where
tell everyone where they can find you um
that way if they want to follow you and
follow the news yeah for sure so at erin
partners i think my ad is up here or
other side yeah there we go right there
right there right there uh at aaron
partners is my twitter and my instagram
and then just throw the number six at
the end aaron parnas6 and that's my tick
tock i post every hour there um updates
and clips so make sure to go check it
out
uh thank you for joining us aaron
everyone go go follow aaron on all the
socials
and keep up with him he's on the
instagram the tick tock the tiki talks
and the tweety tweets thank you so much
yeah hey thanks for joining us erin
everyone stick around we'll be right
back
uh after these messages with the [ __ ]
list roundup thank you aaron we'll see
you soon thank you bye-bye
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast